hallo zweiten video heute aber mit schon
einmal gehört wenn ihr jetzt noch nicht
weiß worum es hier geht dann habt ihr
vermutlich das erste video noch nicht
gesehen was er genau hier finden könnt
ich probiere mich in sieben tagen und
jetzt bis tag vier bis sieben und wir
zeichnen wir uns erst mal um probieren
die games finden was man denn so
titulieren kann es schon am zeichnen ich
starte jetzt
[Musik]
so alles komplett vergessen hatte ist
dass nicht nur die dabei ist sondern wir
jetzt auch mit einer maschine in
tätowieren und nicht mehr hin
ich dachte das wäre ganz cool diesen
fußballer mit reinzubringen weil das ja
eigentlich das echte tätowieren ist und
camp augen ja viel weniger verbreitet
ist gehabt dass ich sie kenne und joggi
ist schon ein bisschen länger macht zwar
auch noch nie auf ihre eigene haut oder
auch irgendwelche haut tätowiert hat
aber zumindest maschinen hat und ja ok
na gut so dass hier ist die maschine im
prinzip ist es gar nicht so viel haben
also man hat hier den strom der leute
rein in so einem netzteil daraus eben
die maschine und hier unten wieder
maschinen
aber das ging mit ihnen ja und das war
dann tut man der nadel rein und dann
steckt man sich da sind ja
[Musik]
wie gesagt für die erste tattoo so
wichtig aber eigentlich der einzige weg
der mann kann bis rauf auf die
eigentliche thema angst weil ich hatte
verpacken kann auch sagen ich hab's ja
nicht wirklich aber das ding ist ich
will halt dass es keine wird weil ich
will hat er sich das kann wenn es nicht
kann habe ich richtig war kann es nicht
funktionieren weil es damals
ich habe die super groß vielleicht immer
aufgetragen damit ist auch die hand dann
ebenso ziehen kann das denn zu verstehen
ist und dann zieht man die verarbeiter
so hoch natürlich glaube ich mal mit
diesen dingen haben weil das kann so ein
bisschen so verwackelt sein
[Musik]
das tut überhaupt nicht weh
roddick serviert jetzt schon 15 minuten
oder so und ein paar sachen aber es geht
folgt also 15 minuten ist schon richtig
stark das lied als so klien aus sowie
klima als alles was ich mit dem handbike
gemacht habe richte crazy dottikon habe
bei den ersten paar minuten schon drei
sachen herausfinden zum einen dass man
viel farbe nehmen muss dass man die
nadel nicht so schnell ziehen kann und
das ist vielleicht am anfang schlau ist
gegen motiv zu nehmen wo die linien
nicht super gerade sind deswegen habe
ich mich dafür entschieden hier so
eingewickeltes fahrrad zunehmend weiß
ich warum ich hab nicht mal ein fahrrad
aber es ist so klien ist so viel kleiner
als alles was ich mit dem herrn programm
gemacht hat ich gespannt wirst du gleich
machen würde das heißt dass wir uns
nicht gut geklappt nicht und ich hoffe
ich mache genau die gleiche erfahrung
und mädchen ab der 5 linie so oft fakt
das wird gar nichts zu tun
ich habe hier schon alles vorbereitet
also ich habe die nadel ich habe die
maschine ich habe ich liebe den ganzen
kram den man so braucht
und was sagen ach ja ich habe mich dafür
entschieden mir einen stuhl zu
titulieren einfach weiß nicht wann es
gibt keinen grund sich sonst ein stuhl
sind genau in der zeit wird die aber ein
weiteres motiv fertig machen was ich mir
danach noch ausgaben machen hoffentlich
und ich bin ziemlich gespannt wie das
wird jetzt wird erstmal hier die nadeln
machen und dann geht es ins denzel
aufgetragen so sieht das aus
daneben seht ihr noch dieses messer dazu
habe ich bisher noch nichts gesagt ist
das interview was ich auch keine einfach
auch noch selber gemacht habe ich finde
dass somit bis beste geworden das habe
ich aber wie gesagt nicht im video
gezeigt lasst uns tätowieren ich habe
jetzt innerhalb von 20 minuten das
tattoo fertig gemacht also schneller als
mit dem herrn bock ist man alle mal ist
es anders aber gefühlt ist es ein
bisschen einfacher und außerdem ist es
wirklich also haben gerade noch mal
drüber nachgedacht völlig crazy dass wir
hier so leichtfertig uns dafür
entscheiden uns einfach irgendwas einen
perfekten stuhl einfach auf die haut
tätowieren weil es halt ich wirklich für
immer bleibt auf der anderen seite denke
ich halt dass es so ich weiß nicht ich
habe lust das zu machen warum sollte ich
mich dann selber aufhalten so alles easy
wenn ich da jetzt noch drauf hat dann
sollte ich das auch jetzt machen weil
das kommt dann vielleicht nie wieder so
das ist okay und so sieht es jetzt aus
ist eigentlich für den ersten 15 dort
viel geworden
jetzt läuft es nicht nur so wird mein
nächster aussehen so überträgt das
gerade für mich weil ich wirklich viel
zu schlecht zeichen kann um das zu
machen
[Musik]
so der ju nummer zwei ist fertig das
tattoo ist fertig wir lassen das jetzt
mal zwei drei tage fahren und dann
schauen wir uns nochmal und was dann
wirklich im endeffekt daraus geworden
ist es bald so sehen die tattoos jetzt
nach zwei tage verteilung aus ich bin
eigentlich super zufrieden damit für so
ne kurze zeit für so wenig ahnung und
ohne dass sich das mit jemandem gemacht
habe der wirkliche ahnung hat und was
mir erklärt hat bin ich mega zufrieden
also ja es ist möglich in kurzer zeit
tätowieren zu lernen nein es ist nicht
möglich das perfekt es ist jetzt so dass
die tattoos so geschaffen sind dass die
fahrer wirklich drin bleibt dass man
erkennt was es ist super clean sind sie
nicht und das was gute tätowierer
ausmacht sind eben ihre motive ihre art
ihr stil um das ist nicht das was man in
sieben tagen findet also man wird kein
tätowierer in sieben tagen man kann aber
in sieben tagen tätowieren am mittwoch
kommt mega geil ist neues projekt
abonniert den kanal um das nicht zu
verpassen und die ganzen anderen videos
die natürlich noch kommen werden
außerdem freue ich mich natürlich über
anregungen in den kommentaren und likes
jackmann dienste ab mittwoch 2 ach ja
ganz vergessen vielen dank
das war megageil es bei ihrem morgen
video schreckt das ab und stieß